this is how it ends
and we let evil win
when the horrific
becomes our new reality I keep having
these dreams not being by
deathstroke and they're not going away we need to do something about
get down
I told you what would happen if the
Titans ever reunited
things are getting super ugly out here
we started this it's all us
hey Stu, how you been I need a new pair of shoes sorry I don't make those anymore
look I don't have a lot of time I'm in
the fruitcake trade now just haven't had
time to change the signage okay I need a
new fruit cake but the maligning of the
fruit cake I will never understand come
here
okay I'm sorry don't be sorry
have a slice it wasn't personal
fruitcake is my life my passion I mean
if you don't like my work I love your work
that's why I came back here would you
like to put a match to this before you
have a slice oh wait I know sure this
should do it right yeah that's how he
likes his fruitcake
I'm sorry I burned your suit I need your
help Stu I need another one something
different
Master Wayne said you'd be coming of
course he did hey Lily hi burning
the suit I had a bad day drama queen
we're moving on Lily all behind us now
let's show him what master Wayne
has put together it's a nomex triple
weave Kevlar shell electrically
insulated and light-sensitive it has
fewer body and lines than the old one to allow you to utilize your circus skills
move more get hit less that was our mantra I like that
the mask has a built-in wireless
transmitter and starlight night vision
lenses
Stu, Lilly
you've outdone yourselves
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my breakdown of the night wing
trailer for Titans their finale is
coming up next week they finally gave
him the costume so we'll break it down
his origin in the reason why he becomes
Nightwing and picks the Nightwing name
is a little bit different on the TV show
too so I'll explain that if you're new
to the channel I do DC videos every week
we're getting ready for crisis on
Infinite Earths be sure to subscribe to
get everything
we're doing a DC merch giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favourite
Nightwing moment from anywhere on the
video so quick backstory on what's going
on all the craziness in this trailer if
you're not caught up on Titans Cadmus
labs took Beast Boy and Superboy and
have been gaslighting them and slowly
brainwashing them for the back half of
the season in order to get them to fight
the other Titans and turn them into
weapons that's how you wind up with this
giant mess at the carnival here in the
finale of this big battle but you also
have them fighting Deathstroke so I'll
talk about that in a second this person
is mercy graves working for Lex Luthor
she's the mercy grace from the comics
she's been the lead person gaslighting
Superboy and Beast Boy this whole time
because Lex Luthor in the Titans
universe owns Cadmus labs just like in
the comics he's the one that bankrolls
the creation of the Conner Kent Superboy
and his origin story is exactly like it
is in the comics half Superman's DNA
half Lex Luthor's DNA he's even wearing
the black shirt with a dark Cadmus logo
meant to be a reference to the black
suit Superman war after reign of the
supermen in the comics where Conner Kent Superboy debuted for the first time but
really we're all here to watch Nightwing
finally show up on the TV show they've
been hinting at it all season long but
we finally saw the suit at the end of
last week's episode as he swoops his
butt in you can see that it's mostly
inspired by the Nightwing rebirth
version of the suit with the giant logo
across his chest
in that scene from the end of episode 11
you see him go to visit the shoemaker so
to speak that makes all of Batman's
suits because he made all the Robin
suits - you probably recognize this
actor from a billion other things the
whole thing with a joke about the
fruitcake him saying fruitcake is his
life
Nightwing saying it's not personal is
just them speaking in code about him
destroying the last Robin suit the
costume designs on this table up front
here are the old Robin suit that he
burned last season they made fun of him
a little bit
for destroying it also here - then they
explained the mechanics of the new
Nightwing suit no more capes no capes
it's much stronger much more flexible
designed to make it easier for him to
fight in a much more acrobatic comic
book Nightwing style they even reference
all of his circus moves so during these
fight scenes that he has with
Deathstroke in the trailer you'll see
the next evolution of his fighting style
and it'll look much more like comic book
night wings fighting style he's also got
those upgraded Escrima sticks that carry
the electrical charge for extra damage
which would be necessary for fighting
someone like Deathstroke who is heavily
armored but also has been enhanced by
hive with a special version of the Super
Soldier Serum if he watched arrow in the
first couple of seasons it's just like
the mirakuru serum only it doesn't make
him crazy like that version of the serum
made that Deathstroke crazy but because
he was dosed with it before he conceived
rose Wilson ravager he passed that on to
her genetically so she can also
regenerate most damage really quickly
nice to finally see her fight him in her
full comic-book uniform we saw that a
couple episodes ago so they've kind of
been doing a version of Judas contract
in the background this season but it's a
little bit different and the person
that's trying to get rid of another Titan is
actually Beast Boy so remember in the
comics originally Tara was supposed to
do Beast Boy but on the Titans TV show
the twist is is that Cadmus labs has
been brainwashing Beast Boy to be the
one to get another Titan and somebody
dies in the trailer it's pretty clear
who dies if you watch the trailer really
carefully they tell you exactly which
one of the Titans they're getting rid of in
the finale because it's right there in
the trailer they've already confirmed
all the members of the Justice League
within this version of Earth but they
haven't introduced their Superman yet
probably because there are so many
Superman coming to crisis on Infinite
Earths between Tom Wellings Smallville
Superman
Brandon rouse Kingdom Come Superman then
you have earth 38 Tyler hoechlin
Superman and the Superman TV show that
the CW is doing with him next year the
other big change for the Nightwing
character on Titans that they've done
from the comics is the reason why he
picks the Nightwing name so on the TV
show they did this arc where he got
stuck in prison while he's in prison one
of his cellmates tells him a legend from
his village about someone called
Al Azul a hero that lives between the
moon in the
stars and in the time of greatest need
he flies down to save you
Dick Grayson says wait a minute you mean
a bird that comes in the night and saves
people and then on the wall there's
graffiti of the night wing symbol with
even like a little mask looking graffiti
symbol next to it so that's meant to be
his inspiration for the night wing name
the reason why he took the night wing
name in the comics is a little bit
different I've already done a video
about that version of the origin story
so I'll link that video at the end of
this it involves a really big crossover
with Superman Batman in the bottle city
of Kandor and it goes way way back to
the classic Superman and Batman comics but just a heads up if you were
wondering Titans has been renewed for
season three I don't know how they're
going to air it because they have a
distribution deal with Netflix but
they're also launching HBO Max and it
seems like the DC streaming service is
going to get folded into that sometime next year or the year after that is getting
really confusing with all the streaming
services rolling out so don't worry when
all that stuff happens I will totally do
a video explaining what's going on but
if you have any big questions just post
them in the comments below remember
finale for titans is next week I will do
a video for that episode and what's
going on during season 3 while you wait
for everything click here for my brand
new Star Wars the Mandalorian episode 3
video best episode so far and click here
for that Titans Nightwing video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!